SK the
releasing start with
driv I'm still doing
releas I
releasing tension back fo
okay since we already saw how much the
glutes were problematic try to let go
okay right here we
go can start doing the same
you're doing the exact same
thing foot on the back
foot for
foot not the heel not the arch
says letop let the or
he
generate get him into drill
two and
I from the back
foot back
foot back foot pressure front foot okay
gra
doing right the first
one don't absorb it don't let your elow
come back
generated
your El CH Rel your ortic
inrees
that the
back watch your elb watch
try do your best to keep your elbow in
the same articulation Ang the same
amount
of from your
rot each timey
to
Mo time not to have
the just
move
Dr is not
back foot foot don't change your
[Music]
elbow elbow don't have the
desire don't
absorb don't
absorb Mo your
elbow sink everything drops the glutes
release good
Sean in the middle
of
L so release is not relaxed okay just
like zazen is not relaxed it's a lot of
energy work okay it's not sleepy
time neither is this release is not
relaxed
okay release is Letting Go okay try it
again
ground ground move the
ground release the desire to throw I
just move I just move
better all the training is in the releas
not whether they move or not whether I
clim at first and then I let go of what
I was clinging
to as we go forward you're not going to
be able to move that
elbow the the the more we change each
drill the further jump to the next drill
leave the drill where it is it's not
that big a step to the next one
watch the
rotation let your feet
go you rotated don't rotate it's not hip
rotation back
forward leave my elbow where it is
so you you have it there
only when you come back and you feel
that way you're trying to go above
it as you feel it release more
move relase you're going to have let's
say 11
10 but as I increase the y i
I
have
I level 10 and try to stay at level 10 I
can't get through it so as I increase
the Y if the G I have to keep releasing
that's why we're doing
it it's another chance of letting go
okay
yes yes
the
rotation
yes l
all right drill is the same mechanics
only I don't I have to the release quick
okay okay
try
release don't forget how fast you come
in is going to be how fast you come out
so train at your level okay the
mechanics are irrelevant of what it does
get
let
ground on your
own let me give
you
between we catch
here with the hour spiral catch with the
hour spiral
catch with
the
extend
extend okay try that get combine it with
a little external
don't don't turn you're not going to
turn back
forward no no no no no no the SP don't
don't turn because you want to come back
forward but we're not going to rotate
when I do it just the catch and then it
goes
out now bring your elbow boxes the our
style is enough
[Music]
absorb every time all right that's your
level okay 50% of the time not training
when you
catch catch my
TR okay
Oran
there that is
[Music]
foot your projection
foot TR
is what we were doing yesterday seated
without the second move
got
[Music]
three two go
yep
find his find his here I am on your arm
here I go in your
but your arm wa your body
[Music]
okay
try don't go it'sing don't go around the
heav
release use the back
is keep that back fo
down you're in the heavy part
for the heavy part
okay let's take
that it's right here the
same right on
this lower the head
around lower the
head
okay don't go around the center Round
the back foot release the tension
that's all it you could be on the
outside if you want it's just to lower
his head this time is like bowling
don't
step Let's uh go in stages
here we take the the back foot
ground it's right
here okay got it everyone see it forget
if you can do it or not just you see it
you see
it
it's here
it okay to get
there I have to he's pushing I'm going
to yield out of the way and I'm going to
start the Bight rotating he goes around
me with his head that's this
hand so the back hand comes
inside goes around the
outside go around
me he's going
up so we'll take this hand away he's
pushing
I don't the
way so not going to contest I'm external
then I'm on the outside and he goes
around
I want his head low
though
down that this is the
back initial back hat okay try
and around
you and you shouldn't have to fall
because we don't have a topsy turby
aspect to it you could run out of
it you want to fall you can
fall that's it that's
it I don't know what you're doing
start with two hands Sean and I'll walk
you
in okay and just wait wait there okay
let go of your right hand it's the left
hand that goes over the top to the
outside e me
no right foot you me left foot ton to
4:00 no your right foot you me to three
left there you go don't cut down it's
supposed to go around
don't cut down you're just going around
you and you lower your base don't you
need you need more base for that
dude you're going to step your
feet what pushup okay here is your Yong
Yong Clash you guys see it okay
we go back
step okay CU there your two hands let
go get out of
the start with two hands let it go
out okay let's do that first go start
with two hands let go to the front hand
get out of the way
start with two hands let go to the front
hand get out of the
way and they're
pushing just like all the other
drills they're pushing from the back
foot through
you go over the
top over the top don't cut him down so
was it yesterday that I said that each
little piece is
incrementally getting them do you get it
right so that would mean the last move
is not doing it all but nor is the first
move okay got it so stop cutting down
like you're he's supposed to flip at
that point we want his we want his
energy to keep going
forward we don't want his energy
to stop I don't want his energy to
stop his energy keeps going
forward
[Music]
long that's the first
move okay try it again
elongation make sure he comes around
your head so your arm and your claw have
to come open
try not to bend or extend your
elbow move your body so the elbow can
keep its articulation and do its job
spir head Di
el
el I don't move my
elow that's it
not too much don't don't bring it back
to you just turn it
it won't be the back diagonal if I'm
facing that
diagonal you should face you
that into
this
reverse your
okay so we're we're we're going to go
into the x pattern that's what we're
trying to do
okay so we from weapons we already know
I got to I got to rotate this cross I
only have two ways
inward outward we're going to use
outward this time this way
okay my body is
oriented this way not
hips okay shift my
way let the arm fall
out there goer
go around the contentious Point shift
your way and let the arm
fall and it'll come this
way shift your
way let your arm
let your
arm
thank don't forget to shift your weight
let your arm
fall your way don't pull let your arm
fall is the exact opposite of P
arm your way F your way to get to the
other side of his
arm don't not to be on top of it
your
we shift your weight don't turn your
hips we're going to shift our weight
just like the
drill don't pull
okay so just like I don't want this
contestation those are cultivation
drills I don't want this cult this one
either I'm going to move my
body so that I get around it
and then don't here not here I get on
the other side of
it on the not cutting in on the other
side of it and I just let my
hand I am trying not to push on anything
not pull on anything they got to get not
here not here so not there not there
over the top of
it how step shift over the top let your
arm fall and he will come
around we'll go to two hands now we
ignore this
hand
boom boom on the other side
around no no over the
top on
theide relax okay
try don't push down
Pull I want you to start to lower it
with your
STS don't use the second arm yet if you
if you're totally going to bite it roll
but you shouldn't really have
to round it maybe a little deeper step
hi yes
yes use your knife edge you're trying to
pull don't push over the
keeping how
you I'm going get you there first
neutralize this move to the
side push into don't push into this very
you okay relax now instead of pulling
there that's telling you don't pull
there instead go this way okay and then
step here this way here yeah that's it
that's
it this pressure that you feel that we
were training with you're going to
neutralize it's off no now it's back
on obstacles telling me where to move
push
here shut them both off just like the
weapons today
okay so good off
here good okay don't
pull step your body so that works that's
feel the
pressure so you came offure
they're just puzzles they're just
physical puzzles just physical Yin
puzzles resist resist the
temptation no
so I can't to do the x pattern my feet
can't make it my feet can't do it uh if
I want his head to go over there my feet
can't do it because we hav a change
relationship you see that so my feet
don't paint the x
pattern
boom okay my foot is going to allow my
shoulder and my hand here to get over
the top of this you see that so I get
over the
top got it then I lower my
center and I'm over the top
completely
okay the way his leg works when you do
this is it goes to the
outside he's terrible at this like
without controlling for it let go let's
see what I mean so we're going to use
that just be
patient Bo just
wait okay got it so don't paint with
your feet don't paint the whole x with
every part of your
body that's what I meant when I say one
move's not to win at all okay
what should I concentrate on pressure
pressure
off
obstacle over you see okay lower
yourself not by bending at the wa just
lowering right lower
your TR again you're trying not to feel
him in other words go just likee weapons
don't feel their power don't feel their
strength don't feel their pressure take
the pressure
off over the top Palm up is going to not
be over the
top good that's it that's all that's all
we need not going to th more
technique side F
lower again you went half body other
half body it happens together things
move at the same
time that's
it release as you're doing it all
like the other we're not going to do
anything just keep it in zero
pressure there the the pressure is
telling you where you can move your feet
how you can move your hand so if you
feel the pressure increase stop moving
don't keep moving okay
go good
good just like weapons don't contest go
around
hey I can't make you stop okay do you
understand I can't make
it you have to make your
your I can't do it I can't get in there
if I can you be saved instantly
but would you really if I was the one
who saved you would you really be saved
if I saved you now you have to save
yourself okay so you have to be the one
that stops fighting you stop fighting
you stop fighting you okay not me I
already gave the information you already
felt it it's all you
need you don't need another
lifetime can be done in this lifetime
let's
go you got to get over the top your
leg that's lower your feet I already
told you that you're a tall dude take
advantage of it this is this is not H me
this is Kam how deep should you go do
you think as deep as I need that's
right
good just go around the outside don't
cut on the top of his wrist outside
that's it try not to feel anything like
you pulled
her over the top turn to your
knife so let's do a little Discovery
learning
am
not it's equal he goes here he goes
there
it's like yesterday where the elbow is
in a certain place remember and it's
going to push him down so he lifts up on
the hand
it makes him go down okay he's going to
try to lift on the hand to try to not
fall that's what actually grows okay but
if you canest and stronger than you
you're not going to work okay
so your palm down you're going to be on
top right your fingers parallel you're
going to be on top your palm up you're
going to be on top you have to point
your fingers down at the
mat just like you have to in
each okay there no advantage to him
try push it on the pushing get there
can't go around
it keep rotating across like we
get to the other
side get to the other side fingers down
don't pull him H it on
his separate your feet you're a tall guy
too separate your feet so you can take
advantage of getting to the other side
of his
arm don't paint the a
fing are down don't go up don't go up
and then
down
down that's it
try not to feel
him good
get over the top get over it get over it
your foot is your knee look how your
knee wants to go past your toes it's
telling you I should have Ste
further don't cut
down just let him fall just keep
contesting for you to cut down you you
would have felt his hand again
here like this and here I don't feel
this hand until I go back like that you
see I keep going over the top of
his over
to don't cut down don't cut back cut
back you're going to cut you're going to
cut in his on okay try it again go
around the energy
around all the way around all the way
around don't push it don't s
itep a little
step that's it don't pull get on the
other side no just try to get right
there don't cut back here we
[Music]
go okay
you want them to pull on you push on you
but you don't do it on
them okay now you make someone go topy
turby his head has to be lower than the
hip if his head is here that hip has to
go very very high if the head is low
it's not very high to push the inside
hip over so it behooves you to lower the
hand because then it's easy to
go don't lower the head and this won't
cause
turning lower the head so we're doing
everything you're just doing but I
have a lower to
it I want to pay attention to where his
head
is okay same thing but now we're making
sure his head gets below his the lower
the better okay
lower it lower it lower it
[Music]
ready okay
don't push the other arm up cuz we're
not going to do that we're going to do
the opposite of that that'll make the
stepping stone much further
away just let it hang down for
now let it hang down that's
it trying to lower his
head without pulling it down cutting it
down pulling it around same thing so all
I do is lower my stance which means my
Center gets closer to the ground by my
feet separating
you're getting triggered just go
slow smooth feel you feel the thoughts
feel the
emotions but not sleeping
[Music]
recile all
pressure let that hand hang
okay put technique on your mind on the
back get
here okay
now just shift your
weight this drill is for
the
okay boom get his head low turn his palm
towards
him shift your
weight and he will use that energy to
find
his Shi my weight
tr get there
that's
it just nice slow
gradual you brought your hand up
Chris Palm towards
him slow down
wait that's not
the okay so moving move that foot into
it move that foot there you go okay then
down here
Rel head down turn your palm go up his
arm in
second okay try
is your KN
get is your KN
getting so when they're
cold it warm it warms up after you
stop get his head down same first
part separate your feet separate your
feet rather than bend your knees okay
and then push that left hand into a
center not don't face the
so what I mean by
that I'm not going to
make ler
his head don't pull that hand you can
only go you can only lower it where it
is so you want your left hand to be
lower
right you pull it right going like
this going here everything fine and then
you like that that's going to
give is now using me for balance that's
what I want okay
then boom very soft here my way
okay try it this like weapons
to wait when you do it so when you first
lower you're here and as you throw
you're here
yes shift your weight
that's it keep the arch up on the back
foot don't pull you step too far around
and now you have to
pull good in the
center remember the center goes with the
other cross doesn't follow the left
yeah turn your hand right all right
remember this is supposed to be UK
Dr sure F A
Lot Dr
[Music]
so when I do the first drill I
organized second drill
organized right uh third Dr
organiz this drill
organized
organiz organized
okay I can't be like
this okay so I also was told that when
I start like
this so now I again
in and I
organized not here I organized you see
you could Pro
that he yields I'll fall into it same
thing I
organized okay
Bo he goes to change my angle I keep my
organization and still
here I'm not going to go like this
keep going keep
going
okay smooth
okay let's try it
again again you're going to go is how
you going to land okay that's what we're
interested
in so right there we been bring your
foot up on the back foot and reach out
with your
spine that's it find the roll slowly
From Here let go let go
remember that projecting arms on the
different
angle the head comes around me the hips
go away from
me reach
out go over the top of his come under
[Music]
CER so let's look at what we're doing
pushing and I started in that
relationship I am going to come to the
90 and start this thing rotating this
way as it rotates this way I'm in the
middle of
it I want the head to go here but I
don't want his hips to follow him I want
his hips to go that
way his head goes this way his hips go
that way his feet are going to go this
way from the Cal
energy
so if you
go his hips are going that way his
head's coming this way and his feet are
going that
way it
I have the two extremities of this body
going in entirely different
directions one on a straight line one on
the
Cur I have the um sorry the middle of
his body I have his feet which
constitute a basic support going into an
entirely different direction from the
center okay so here what I've done is
the center and the head are no longer in
vertical alignment to each
other and his feet are no longer
underneath him so he can stand
understand
okay not only
that but his head's over here on this
trajectory is
Center is going over here
on that trajectory and his feet are on
this trajectory over here now he has the
fall okay as long as what there's one
more thing I told you
earlier for him to go Topsy tur what his
his head has to go below the hip so this
is two dimensional you have to imagine
it threedimensional about that okay
okay try
give it one more try Ronin just the same
same Pace was
fine okay switch
rolls good good you can you I want you
to work on everything you're working on
but at higher intensity levels he's
going to be fine okay don't go so high
you can't work on it anymore
okay
good keep separating head feet and
Center
yes faster
[Music]
harder Underneath more so you get the
threedimensional
aspect to it
got to lower lower the hand head
high so right under first move his head
goes down on the first move from the
yields down see how high his head is say
what don't his head walk then come
down and Y
down you see it's the same thing he he's
trying he he's grappling me I'm not
going to be good press I'm not going to
be able to make him walk like that and
then push him down okay right where he
goes this is where I got it
okay you understand
so right y down
okay
try if you push on him you're going to
move him not send him
down good that's it
Chris now he's walking he's walking with
his head
up yield head down that's come
underneath make his Center go the other
way
he's walking he's
walking yes Sean that's it that's
it P P him he's going to walk he's going
to reverse the map and we want him
tilting
immediately okay
you'll do two that last pace is
fine x one more more
X make the center go the other
way that's
it we cut down you can this go around
Works come more from
underneath go and now breathe and relax
feel that Center move okay like that
last try again move or
Center not a it's not a momentum
throw okay
[Music]
send it in the opposite angle don't make
it don't let it follow the head
so
close all good but this one's going
the this you want to go
this you see how
now have to barrel roll yes sir because
your Center is not following your head
okay your is not following your head
your feet won't be under you when you
land be over there get it cuz you're
barable okay so watch on someone
else coming
here and you can't accelerate someone
you see kind of what you're doing but I
don't want to accelerate him I want to
deconstruct him so this goes that
way he has to
okay okay try
it sharpen up your x
l don't accelerate him send his basic
support Parts in different
directions this is
kazushi whatever way his head goes it's
the opposite corner okay do that side
again you know which way you're going to
project for
three Underneath Him not over the top
same side
again oh bre
out there
go you go the only he can find that Ro
no blow is not going to find that Ro
okay even you having a hard time finding
that Ro right okay yeah okay so uh don't
count whether whether he crashed or not
he's not going to crash count whether
he's Barrel rolling or whether he's
Somers salting like modern IO does that
somersault roll where the hips follow
the they go it's diagonal on the dock
but it's still hips following this one
he's like this going through space okay
so if you
watch when when he's going I have to do
a barrel
mod you see got it so look more for how
your UK is in space okay if they're
doing a roll like this your hands going
to follow and they can go
like that they can get up okay TR little
bit more then we
stop you can go to the FL count you
going pick up
a here you go you're
fine go with the heavy part of the
center
got to lower his head
more more immediately it drops from the
contestation that's it there you
[Music]
go
okay strong x pattern very distinct X
that's it that's
it don't break
Center all right thank you partner